secret life of pets - yeah you voice
pops yes who are you doing when you do
that character essentially Lionel
Barrymore from It's a Wonderful Life is
the core of a grumpy old man we all have
grumpy old men in our lives like you
know that got your balls going to his
yard you guys mine now right that guy I
like the ball your mind is fine where
Paul is that he's tiny and grumpy and I
hate myself I made inches tall
it's my ping-pong now but I really I
realize they're just a key and lonely
and they're taking it out on humanity
that was on an airplane once I have a
fear fear of flying so I go up and I
entertain the flight attendants because
I makes my brain happy you know eight
8,000 feet in the air anyway so this guy
this old grumpy old man comes out of the
bathroom he goes the sound of your voice
was so greedy
and I was like stunned everyone's done I
go and I just said this isn't about me
it's about you and then he lurched Abbi
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so I'm doing that as a dog a variation
of lionel barrymore to the grumpy old
man I did on Saturday Night Live yes
yeah who actually that twist was that he
loved that things were best it was like
that in my day my day we didn't have
flame-retardant sleepwear if you ain't
have been smoking you woke up and golden
flame we have a clip here this is from
secret light for the pets to take a look
my name's tiny nobody cares I was
teaching tiny how not to be anyone's
sucker word got out suddenly every puppy
in the tri-state area is scratching at
my door yeah oh boo face your pops
yes pickles a girl make a poop oh you
know where to do that find her shoes
well secret like attached to is in
theaters on Friday and do look if that
podcast this summer because I'm really
excited about it Dana Carvey
god
[Applause]